foreign
let's go out to Emily in Salt Lake City
hey Emily what's happening
hello Dr John how are you we're we're
figuring it out today it's a tough one
here in town but we are figuring it out
how are you guys
yes
um you know we're doing okay out here
we don't even know what that means
um how can I help what's up
um so
um you know honestly
um right now I am just
feeling very
overwhelmed
um I'm exhausted I'm exhausted
physically emotionally spiritually any
any way you can think
um what's going on a lot going on in my
life right now but
um I'll kind of share my question and
then I I ask you to please share this
conversation because we don't have three
hours but okay
um but my question is
um how do I tell my children who are
14 13 and 7. the truth about their
father who they love dearly
um I after I've disguised everything as
much as I possibly
could up to this point
and honestly this is
um Coming forth now as an effort to
protect them
and to prepare them for the position
Emily get to it
you were talking in circles after
circles after circles
what did their dad do
um
um and child sexual abuse
no um
hey hold on I'm I'm sorry
I'm sorry
is he coming up on parole
um yes his first parole hearing will be
this summer will he get it
I I honestly
do not know
to to trust this system to
consider me in any of the decisions
um though he did he did get sentenced to
prison but
I don't know I I honestly don't know I I
am preparing my or I'm having to prepare
myself
um for him getting out I I don't see him
how are you how are you preparing
yourself for that because right now it
sounds like you're holding your breath
right now I right now I'm really not
um right now I am more concerned about
just
being able to protect my kids from what
they don't know you used a word
that I want you to be very very careful
of
you use the word disguised
and
that's really close to not telling them
the truth
and I know you're doing it to protect
them to keep them from the hell that you
went through
but in the process of of helping them
and keeping them safe I don't want you
to burn the last relational thing
they're gonna have which is trust in
their mom
okay
no I understand that and that's where
finding a balance is I don't know how
I've
from the time they were born I've you
know I have never involved them in
the arguments or the tension or the you
know anything going on in the home I
tried to they listen Emily they know
fairy tale for them they know
they don't know the specifics
they don't know the details but they
know
I promise you they know
I'm gonna paint you a bleak picture
about the the path this could go on
and then I'm gonna give you some hope
okay
okay here's the Bleak picture
they know they have felt this tension
for years
they've seen Mom disappear
they've seen mom come up with stories
about the
uh why is Dad not here tonight what does
that scrape from Mommy what happened to
your
to your eye mommy like they've been
asking these questions for years they
know
but when they don't have any part of the
picture the full picture they may never
know and that's okay
but having any sort of inkling that
there's a picture
what happens is he gets out or they
visit him or they take a phone call with
him and he can paint a pretty clear
picture that mom's crazy
and your mom did this and suddenly
in a distorted puzzle all of their
confusion and frustration and absorption
of all that tension that they've
experienced over the years they get a
picture for it
and the puzzle pieces lock into place
and he suddenly is able to drive the
narrative see what I'm saying
I do I feel like that that has happened
their whole lives it has you know he's
had no problem you know telling them you
know Mommy doesn't want Daddy living at
home anymore
to you know I I have never been able to
say one one negative thing about their
dad right so here's what we're gonna do
this is not a conversation for you to
have by yourself you've got to get a
counselor
a trained counselor
especially with the 14 and 13 year old
and probably a play therapist with the
seven-year-old that that's kind of on
the border it will depend on the uh
maturity and wisdom of your
seven-year-old
um in fact I'm thinking about my kids I
would go One Direction with one in
another Direction with the other
but you are going to have a counselor
walk you and your child individually
through
um this conversation
and the reason we're gonna have a
counselor number one is we have what we
have to do is do something called we
trying to think of uh Layman we gotta
create safety we have to teach these
kids how to self-regulate when they hear
their everything they know about their
world is upside down
yeah and so there's going to be somebody
that teaches both of you and they're
going to watch you breathing exercises
writing journaling drawing pictures
thinking of things
you know uh
going for walks catching your breath all
these things in a like a seeking safety
protocol so that we can get to
the reason that he's in jail his daddy
hurt mommy really really bad for a long
time
and then that kid is going to hear that
from a counselor and is going to look
directly at you
and then that kid is going to feel shame
that they didn't see it they're going to
feel ashamed that they didn't stop it
they're going to feel all sorts of shame
that part of them is their dad and how
could I do that right all that stuff
that stuff's gonna happen and having
them have an already established
relationship with a professional
therapist is critical
okay
you don't do this one on your own
especially not now
if you just took one of your kids out to
McDonald's and said hey I've got some
stuff some hard stuff I got to tell you
you are going to make them have to I
mean you're gonna so distort their world
they're gonna have to run to what's safe
and what's comfortable and
um they're gonna be ripe to be filled in
with stories either way
dad's evil mom's crazy back and forth
and back and forth
I want to go to the counselor I'm gonna
slow play this and slow play this and
say it in a way and then at some point
they'll bring the whole family in
because you'll have the what do we do
now conversation
and by the way
these records down the road
might be what's used in a parole hearing
or in a custody hearing
okay
okay so that when you tell that that 14
year old who's now 15 or 16
I'm not when you're 18 you can do what
you want to do your daddy is not safe
and so I am making the choice to keep my
kids safe and I understand that you miss
your dad I miss him too
but I'm safe now
see what I'm saying
yes I do it's a it's a tough messy thing
but can I ask you one hard question
underneath all of this
yeah
well I won't ask that question I'll ask
it in a different way
um
let me make a statement instead of
asking you a question I don't put you on
the spot that's kind of a mean question
I was going to ask
the greatest gift you can give those
kids
is you believing
that you are worth being well too and
you do not believe that
true or false
um
true
I feel like the energy that I can muster
up I
I owe it to my kids to make sure that
they're okay
I don't feel like I have time for both
at some point
because you choose to not take care of
you
they lose their mom
don't let that happen
you've heard this said a thousand times
in a thousand different places
when the plane goes into distress you've
got to put your oxygen mask on first
so that you can make sure every one of
those kids gets their oxygen mask on
but if you instantly start grabbing for
three kids who are a mess trying to get
their masks on and they're fighting you
and yelling you and taking them off when
you get them on pretty soon you pass out
and you're getting real close to your
Edge right
I am yeah
I know that because the his parole date
his get out date is getting closer
and
you can't think of that day even
your body still goes into
pure survival it goes back to Hell into
those hard evil moments
you gotta make a call today
foreign
Emily
and I I want you to do this for you but
if if doing it for your kids helps you
make that first phone call and go to
that first and and the first one will be
easier than the second one second the
second counseling session will be
brutal the third one maybe even more so
I went to had a two-hour session the
other day and it was rough
but I'm telling you on the other side of
this
is a Clarity an ability to sleep an
ability to sit down across from an
attorney
and not have your body go to fight or
flight but to be able to say no no I
don't think you understand this is how
this is going to go
it's a world that you haven't
experienced in so long because you were
married to a person who hurt you all the
time
will you take care of my friend Emily
when I say that I don't want you to
think of that as an extra chore when I
say I want you to take care of my friend
Emily that means I want you to go sit at
the feet of a professional and say
I'm ready for healing I'm ready to get
help I'm ready for
this pain to stop so that I can love
those kids
so that I can love those kids
want you to hang on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy of own your past change
your future just for you you may have
already read it and if you haven't
um it's it's worth reading
um
there is no mistaking this you got a
tough road to hoe I mean it's going to
be a long journey forward
ask around get a couple of friends get a
couple people at your local church if
you go to church find some folks who
have a counselor that they trust and
reach out to that person
and your counselor should be able to
refer you to some childhood counselors
in the area so that they can help
facilitate these conversations there are
people who are specifically trained to
have these hard conversations with kids
it's both delicate and very direct and
it's uh it's a process
please keep me up to date let me know
how things are going and call anytime
and I'll walk alongside Emily every
single step of the way